[Music]
preparations are underway as we're
getting closer to the Las Vegas Formula
One races tonight we move into the next
round of closures for phase one of the
repaving process on the Las Vegas Strip
Madison Kimbrough is near at Las Vegas
Boulevard and Harman tonight where the
second round of work will start this
evening Sasha luckily the work isn't
being done during the day as you can see
it's pretty busy out here for Easter
Sunday but tonight at 9 00 PM expect
those restrictions to be in place in the
area as five Lanes moves to four now the
entire repaving process will last until
September and be divided into six parts
throughout the next several months last
weekend the focus was on sands Avenue
near the MSG sphere while tonight's
construction will begin on the Las Vegas
Strip from Sands to Harmon here's what
some locals in the area had to say about
the preparation first time I lived here
there was 300 no 700 000 now there's
over three million so I think the city
does a fantastic job of keeping up the
roads are well done well marked I have
no problems with it a final round of
Paving will happen where Crews will lay
down two inches of dense asphalt to make
the racetrack surface now that will
happen closer to when the race starts in
November as for construction here the
repaving from Sands and Harmon will last
until May 19th reporting here at Harmon
and Las Vegas Boulevard Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now
the price tag for the repaving project
has not been announced but lvcva
President Steve Hill has indicated that
F1 has asked for help and F1
spokesperson declined to provide any
updates on the project